STEPHANIE WONG: So we
have our Hipster Shop app.
And we've been talking
a lot about Istio.
But when you have Istio managing
microservices, why would
we need API
management and Apigee?
MARUTI C.: Sure, I get
this question all the time.
In simple words, Istio is
great to manage microservices,
but when developers decide
to share those services
to other teams of
external developers,
they need to publish an API.
A successful API needs
to be easily consumed.
That's really peer
management concept.
With Apigee, you can easily
employ standard API management
capabilities.
STEPHANIE WONG: Sounds like
a helpful set of features.
Can you show me how
I can get this setup?
MARUTI C.: Sure.
Let me show you how it works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's use Hipster
Shop app for the demo.
Hipster Shop app is an internal
microservices application
and the best app where users
can browse items, add them
to the cart, and
purchase them, which
is running entirely
on Kubernetes
and managed by Istio.
This is the service architecture
of the Hipster Shop app.
So far, the shipping
service is utilized only
by the internal microservices.
Now we want to expose the
shipping service as a tracking
API to the third
party developers,
so they can take
advantage of a service.
Let's go back and expose
the shipping services
tracking API using
this virtual service.
Tracking in the
API part is pointed
to their shipping service,
which is running on Kubernetes.
Once the service
is created, let's
access the API to see if
it is created successfully.
And we can retrieve the tracking
details of the tracking ID.
Once the necessary Apigee
provisioning is taken care of,
these definitions here are
to configure the Apigee Mixer
and Istio so that we can
start using the capabilities.
Let's look at some of the
things we can do in Apigee.
This configuration
tells Istio to send
all the required
attributes to Mixer
for each transaction,
which will be forwarded
to Apigee for
analytics reporting
and apply rules to traffic
flowing through this Istio
service mesh.
Once the configurations
are set, let's
create a rule to
capture analytics
for all the inbound calls
to the microservices.
This records all the
inbound defined fields
and forwards to Apigee
for analytics reporting.
Let's go to the
Apigee management UI
to access the outer
box reports to view
the metrics for all
the microservices
for an individual service.
This particular dashboard,
Proxy Performance,
displays the total traffic
success and failure metrics.
There are out-of-box
reports and custom reports
to get various metrics
like error code
and latency and more.
We have an API,
but we don't have
a way the developers
can start using
it to create developer apps.
To permit that,
let's create an API
from the Apigee
Edge Management UI.
For this product, we'll
call it as Take5 product.
This is a place
where the API team
can define the access level
settings, quarter settings,
including all of the
shipping service resources
that the developer
applications can access.
This is a service
name of the shipping
service and Kubernetes.
Once the API product is
created and available,
developers can go to the
Hipster Shop developer portal
to test the API and
create their apps.
Let's look at the API
product and tracking
API that is published.
As there is no security,
any one that is logged in
can access the API and
return the tracking details.
In this case, the API
team is unaware of who
is accessing the API and is
unable to enforce controls.
Let's protect the API.
This rule helps in safeguarding
the inbound traffic
to the shipping service
with an API key.
As a next step, we'll
apply that rule.
Developers can't access the
API without a key, which they
can get by creating an app.
Let's go back to the
developer portal.
Log in as a developer.
Create an app and
access the API.
This application will be
called as Hipster Demo App
and will copy the key
that is generated.
If you access the API as
a developer without a key,
it should fail, as we don't
have the authorization headers.
Now, let's make the same
call with the right header
to be able to read through
the tracking details
to the successful response.
By doing all of
this, you can see
that Apigee is doing the
API key verifications,
security is enforced,
and the API key is valid.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
So with Apigee I
can manage my APIs
so other developers can build
applications on top of mine.
MARUTI C.: Exactly.
Istio and Apigee can help
you build your application
and make it too cool for school.
If you like what you saw,
make sure to like, comment,
and subscribe.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us
or know more about Istio,
Apigee, and microservices
click on the links
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]